hi I'm John Mulaney and this is life
advice I don't know if I'm very good at
giving advice I haven't had many life
experiences I've never been in a fight
you can probably tell that by looking at
me I don't have any children I've been
married for like two weeks and I'm a
terrible driver
but yeah I'll take a crack at altering
your life why not the worst piece of
advice I ever got is very interesting it
was that everyone has HPV so you
shouldn't worry about it you're
definitely going to get it these are
questions these are real questions these
are real questions from readers all
right my boss wants me to buy weed for
him but I've never bought it before and
I have no idea where to get it do I have
to the question is do I have to I
thought the question would be where to
get weed do you have to know although
what country are you in North Korea yeah
you probably don't have to do it because
like if he fires you for not buying him
weed that's what they call lawsuit I
made a big deal about quitting my job
last year to become a stand-up comedian
is this me comedy is not working out
this is me is there a way for me to ask
for my old job back but that's a big
desperate oh so he does he or she
doesn't want advice about being a
stand-up comedian which I might be able
to help with maybe they want advice on
whether it's too late to ask for their
old job back without seeming desperate
boy it depends on how they quit doesn't
it the idea of pooping at work freaks me
out be an adult say [ __ ] the idea of
[ __ ] at work freaks me out what
should I do
I work really long hours a long way from
my apartment well that doesn't matter no
no one's recommending you go back to
your apartment and I need a lot of
coffee to function okay you are a very
you're very upset
it sounds judgmental but you're a very
flawed person you need a lot of coffee
to function so you're exhausted you
can't sleep at night freaks you out
[ __ ] at work why are the stall doors
thin short what's the problem I don't
know where you work
and there might be like Vogue magazine
or something where you just can't
destroy a bathroom then go back to your
desk I love giving advice yeah cuz I get
to talk and hear myself talk and that's
a good time
I'm 29 work in a coffee shop and have
literally no idea what I'm going to do
with the rest of my life is it okay if I
have no ambition it is totally okay
there is far too much ambition in this
world work is not a good thing income
and food and shelter are a good thing
working hard is not a good thing it is
the thing that we have decided is a good
thing because we don't want to be around
our family are you happy do you you have
coffee you have access to coffee in a
bathroom that's all you need
we've heard from other people today who
don't even have access to those things
count your blessings don't work hard
[ __ ] wherever you want be an adult you
know who cares no one's paying attention
to you there's something that's good
advice no one's paying attention to this
was life advice with me John Mulaney
thank you for watching
[Music]